male body dysmorphia is on track to
overtake female body dysmorphia within
the next few decades does that surprise
you no I think it's always been a thing
but especially now with how big social
media is and how jacked so many people
are uh I think of course it's a it's a
big problem but do you know there's a
guy who's really good at calling people
out for editing their photos have you
seen that guy I don't know his name but
he's got quite a big social media
following and basically anybody who has
photos shops their photo or videos M he
gets them oh wow so he's doing a good
job
he's making sure that people are being
truthful with the things that they're
posting but that makes you think how
many people are editing even people who
are literally jacked and shredded they
are still editing their photos further
to bring in their waist bring out the
lats and just it's crazy so especially
with women as well imagine how bad that
is for the average person who's
comparing M themselves to all these
people and a lot of those people are
actually still editing their photos to
look moreable peaked they've just
trained they've got a pump they're in
good lighting they've got a good
photographer a good camera good lens
they've got a tan blah blah blah and
then on top of that they're editing
their photos as well yeah it it's you
know I think that that's it's one thing
that messed me up a little bit when I
competed so I competed twice and
obviously when you compete that really
is the best that you are going to look
probably in your life especially for me
in terms of how low I got my body fat
percentage so when I would look in the
mirror particularly after the show when
it was like more
memorable I would be like pretty fat
because you had yourself because I was
comparing myself to the sub 10% body fat
person that I was looking in the mirror
which is like that says it all that not
only can you have other people out there
in the world for guys and girls that
make them feel uncomfortable about their
body or they're taller or more jacked or
more whatever but you can also be that
for you too you know this is I wanted to
talk about this like you know you're 34
33 33 I'm 35 and we're getting to the
stage where we're like right okay you
know recovery from workouts takes a
little bit longer recovery from nights
out takes an awful lot longer a couple
more wrinkles on the forehead my
photographer keeps reminding me of that
cheers Rob don't listen to don't listen
to them uh yeah just thinking about as
that happens you almost use yourself as
well I used to be X or Y as I used to be
this able to get up and and train hard
or lift this much or be this lean or eat
this many calories or whatever and then
you can't so you use yourself as your
own barometer and you know the
discomfort that's associated with that
of not being as jacked as you used to be
not being as able to recover from work
as you used to be it's like a harsh
realization like the the body smoria I
think with me in particular I've I've
not really been that person that's
always compared myself to others but
more so I'm always comparing myself to
myself and how good I have looked in the
past that's what I'm always comparing
myself to and you're right I think
fortunately for me now I still feel like
I'm I I don't know if I have peaked I
think especially if I was to fine-tune a
few things M the peak is still yet to
come but when I do have these thoughts
of okay well Sony downhill from here
yeah that I'm like you do know that I I
think about that and this whatever you
want to call about it like aging
gracefully as a man whatever that means
right uh probably not taking all of your
selfworth from the way you look might be
a good place to
start and I think God you know how
difficult it's going to be recovery from
the workouts and not being as Jack not
being the fastest guy in the room or the
strongest guy in the room or whatever
but then you realize that that's like
women from age 25 yeah I think we we as
men have got it good like we can we can
get older and age and get the the the
gray whiskers more wrinkles and if
anything it's still kind of it might
even make you look better like I
remember I looked back at some footage
from when I
was even like 20 27 28 and I feel
personally I look a lot better now like
I had like maybe it didn't help that I
was like clean shaving myself all the
time but I looked you grow into with
your style a little bit but yeah you
know for for all that I can be
chronically fearful of my own mortality
and getting older and all the rest of it
thinking yeah but the speed of descent
isn't as rapid as it is for yeah women
so yeah the male body dismorphia thing
being on track to overtake female body
dysmorphia kind of doesn't surprise me I
think you you probably have to be
careful with who you're following and
who you're comparing yourself to like if
if you were an average guy and you are
following the like top 1% of athletes in
the world the top
0.01% of course you're going to feel
pretty small in comparison to them so it
depends like for someone like me if I am
following like the elite you trained
with Kai green this morning yeah so but
in town at the moment so if I if I'm
following them I'm the type of person
that gets inspired by it like I get
motivated by that but other people can
take it the opposite way and be like oh
that's unachievable I'll never get there
and I feel worthless yeah what's your
relationship like with social media
now
oh I
think I would love to not have to be on
it so much but I know it's something
which I need to be doing regularly more
than ever like you especially with what
we do in today's day and age you have to
be
everywhere um even to this day I don't
like how I still get sucked into it
every single time in terms of the the
Doom scrolling I go on there to do a
task then I get distracted by something
and then I'm scrolling then I still
haven't done the like oh 15 minutes
hell hang on I didn't do the
thing I supposed it so you have to go
back onto it again so I think um yeah
from that point of view I hate how good
it is at just sucking you in and
rewarding you for just getting like a
notification or whatever
um in terms of like YouTube and stuff
I'm I'm I'm quite selective with what I
consume like I when I go on to YouTube I
like to watch things which I'm going to
No Doubt get educated by I like to watch
a lot of podcasts anything which I'm
going to learn something by Instagram as
well it's it's it's a bit of a mess I
have it I like now to employ as many
people as possible to just run the
platform yeah so that I don't have to go
onto it I still
still actually it's a recent thing I
don't look at comments anymore okay that
used to still mess with your head I
think particularly like with the the gym
related videos I would do a gym workout
or try and do an educational video
talking about like uh how to do this
exercise or whatever and then the
comment section is all steroids steroids
steroids steroid steroids why you lying
to us fake Natty and it's just like I'm
I'm trying to help people yet the the
whole conversation is about whether or
not I'm natural and it used to annoy me
so much that I actually pivoted away
from making gym videos because it was so
annoying that because no one's talking
about your supposed steroid use in a
lifestyle Vlog in Marb yeah so like the
the less gym related stuff in it there's
kind of less uh negativity dude I mean
that's that's something that's really
true that the audience gets to influence
the direction of the Creator in a lot of
ways and if they make them feel very
uncomfortable about whatever it is that
they're doing going to start to lean
away from that typee of content was one
of the reasons why I got hair transplant
cuz when I was losing my hair and it was
thinning really badly when I look back
at it now I was like like it was pretty
bad and I was like I don't ever remember
it being that bad I was there was a a
six-month phase where probably should
have just shaved it like you know how
when everyone's losing their hair they
try and just cling onto it and you just
got like little strands just you know
it's looking pretty pathetic and lonely
and the whole comment section was just
about ah he's losing his like oh the
steroid again and it was just like I'm
making these videos yet all everybody
wants to talk about is the hair loss
yeah well we spoke about this the last
time that I had you on I I mentioned
that I admire the fact that you've
chosen to stay out of Internet drama
yeah as best you can I think that's
partly both yours and my disposition
which is I'm just not very conflict
person I quite like having been chill
and and peaceful and relaxing and I'm
not in it for the beef but there's
certainly it feels extra unfair if you
haven't done made a career out of like
James Smith right my partner in neonic
he made a career calling people out for
like Fitness advice or for lying
about stuff or for editing photos or for
do being you know
unethical it's kind of Open Season for
him because guess what like that the way
that you went about think I knew like as
we were in the buildup launching this
drink and he started doing call out
videos about Prime and everything else
and I was like James you do know that by
doing this you're just making it open
season on us but anyway for him it's
like all right well you know if you've
spent a lot of time criticizing other
people it's kind of Open Season on you
that's not to say that people who've
never criticized should be insulated
from any
criticism but it's just like hang on
what have I done to you why you dragging
me into this yeah in a way I was it's
kind of good in one sense because it's
exposure but when it is a person of
authority talking about you then
they have a a huge audience who do
listen to every word that they say big
influence and it's kind of a it's a only
one argument is being put forward of
course you could do a response video and
give your side of it but where does it
end and then they're like yes he I've
got him I've got him yeah yeah but I
think you know even for the people that
aren't content
creators every everybody especially with
Tik Tok Tik Tok is
so the number of followers you have
basically doesn't count if you put an
insane video on Tik Tok guess what
there's a million likes on it you know
if it's really really good and you catch
the algorithm at the right time etc etc
which means now that
everybody content creator or mother that
happens to take a funny video of her dog
doing something is open to the entire
internet saying oh that's that's animal
abuse or whatever you know what I mean
like there's just everybody's open to
criticism and I think
some kind of education about how to deal
with
criticism from strangers on the internet
would probably be a pretty good thing
yeah for everybody to learn yeah uh well
I remember when I started with YouTube I
think whenever you're on a platform that
people can post anonymously they'll go
harder they'll be more Relentless with
what it is that they want to say and I
think that took me a bit of getting used
to and I almost had to learn okay I got
to develop thick skin here in order to
just carry on with doing it I mean even
the people who are like the the nicest
guys ever that you would just and girls
you just think how can you not like this
person like such a likable person
they're still getting hate for something
tons and tons of distaste yeah well
there's an idea called the bystander
effect have you heard of this no so um
you have a a crime let's say somebody's
being attacked right in the um Courtyard
of a bunch of FL Flats somewhere and
everybody that lives in the flats hears
the attack going on and there's someone
you know screaming for help or saying
please ring the police or whatever all
of the people think that one of the
other people will do the right thing and
call the police or whatever bystander
effect and there's kind of a an
anonymity equivalent here which is when
you know that you're not going to be
found out you can almost lean in and be
a little bit be way more mean no one's
going to come after you you're not going
to be held accountable for the things
you say it's a burner account on YouTube
like you know I mean so dude some of the
stuff like anti-Semitism and stuff
that's happened this year on on like
random comment threads and I'll see
people talking in code about like or
like you know whatever reverse
anti-Semitism crazy crazy crazy stuff
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't it's a
healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks it's got a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and and magnesium you
might ask what do I want with an
electrolyte drink well it'll regulate
your appetite it'll curb Cravings it'll
help improve your brain function best of
all it tastes phenomenal first thing in
the morning this orange element salt in
water is outstanding your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day so it's pointless having a morning
coffee your adrenal system which is what
salt acts on is active so this will make
you feel more alert more awake and
improve your hydration best of all
they've got a no BS no questions asked
fun policy so you can buy it and if you
do not like it for any reason they will
give you your money back that's how
confident they are that you'll love it
head to drink LM nt.com
slod wisdom to get a free sample pack of
all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink LM nt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip then
press here for the full episode in all
its Glory